how I tackle the college admissions is I
looked at where I was at which is my
grades were not the best and so I looked
at all the top schools and I thought
about which one would be easiest to get
into and Stanford is actually up there
before we continue this video I just
want to say thank you so much to audible
for sponsoring this video get your first
audible for free plus two audible
originals when you try audible for 30
days visit audible.com slash Joma or
text Joma at 500 500 so what are
honorable originals well I'm glad you
asked
audible originals are exclusive audio
titles created by celebrated
storytellers from worlds as diverse as
theatre journalism literature and more
so basically there's like sound effects
music voice actors and it's basically
really well produced I myself have been
listening to bad blood by John Kerry you
which is about Elizabeth Holmes and her
startup thoroughness and how she lied
her way into creating a multi-billion
dollar biotech startup Bill Gates loved
it apparently it was one of his
favorites in 2018 I've been using
audible when I do boring stuff like when
I commute when I do laundry when I cook
which allows me to suck in all that
knowledge and become a better me and you
should too so if you're interested don't
forget you can go to audible.com slash
Joma or send Joma to 500 500 to try
audible or free like when I look at your
channel I was that I'm actually like oh
man I kind of want that channel you know
random [ __ ] like if you looked on my
vlogs and some my old videos you would
see that you know it's a lot of random
[ __ ] also yeah and I actually enjoyed
doing that but then it was um it was
because this channel blew up that okay I
have to double down on this right so
it's kind of sad that you see what you
mean yeah I'm always tempted to make
more Stanford videos because it gets
clicks I got abused right but you know I
just want to see whatever yeah but I do
think that like your audience is like
very strong though
yeah I'm really thankful yeah it's a lot
of good means yeah yeah like I think at
the beginning my channel was also like
that like a bit more like me me you know
a lot of like inside jokes and stuff
yeah but but but then like the tech
videos they just like boo me up
something okay I guess I'm gonna keep
doing that right yeah okay cool so all
right let's start the interview I I
always say like I don't wanna you know
make it too much of an interview so if
ever you want to ask me questions you
could ask me questions okay
and what's funny is because like my
viewers are always like dude can you
shut the other person to talk like it's
not always about you Joel McHale so I'm
just telling that like it's not an
interview it's a conversation so that I
can say stuff too yeah so before I start
you want just like introduce yourself a
little bit about your channel what is it
about it Hajis ash feel hi i'm RP park
have a youtube channel check it out hi
doc brought you in because you go to
Stanford and you know Stanford gets a
lot of clicks through I'm gonna use that
on my channel so can I just ask you a
little bit about like your scores first
and then like how did you get in what
did you like why did you think you got
in and stuff like that
ICT I got a 1590 and an AC ticket what
is that out of 1600 canadian sorry all
right
1600s yeah yeah that's pretty good I
think you let Leigh like it's like it's
one point if before the maximum yeah
there's one question mm-hmm always
bummed about rash but I know I just you
know you shouldn't even get accepted to
Stanford
yeah that's pretty impressive so in your
videos you say that you know you don't
study a lot stuff like that yeah
is it true now or is it even true before
because like 1590 that's very like right
you would need to study a lot for now
right so what I'll say about the test
scores is that I think I was just always
sort of lucky with test taking skills
like I didn't study too much for like
standardized tests
I just took like oh wow maybe like three
or four practice tests beforehand and
then usually that be
enough yeah I mean who keeps telling me
it's a meme that I don't study I told
you earlier I'm taking like two classes
right now in high school I'll say I
tried a lot harder I see
only like junior senior year it's cuz I
had like this end goal this holy grail
of getting into standard also you wanted
to get into center right right I wanted
to get into a prestigious school because
what about like Harvard and the other
schools you don't care about them how I
tackled the college admissions is I
looked at where I was at which is my
grades were not the best and so I looked
at all the top schools and I thought
about which one would be easiest to get
into and Stanford is actually up there
cuz they don't look at freshman year and
like I have like a weird set of
extracurriculars so I thought it fits
Stanford best so the decision to apply
to Stanford versus like Ivy League or
whatever was basically just because I
thought it'd be easier to get into
Stanford okay so so you wanted to get
into like Ivy League slash procedure
school yeah and then you thought
Stanford was like the easiest one as
weird as it is to say Stanford seemed
like the easiest option interesting KL
it is here right now oh so I'm gonna I'm
gonna get them so here we have Elliott
now so you want to tell you a little bit
about yourself what your channel where
you talk about yeah I'm a sophomore at
Vanderbilt I am working on a channel
right now that focuses a lot on like
college videos entrepreneurship
lifestyle I'm really into like
videography whatnot but it really
changes up a lot so I'm just trying to
like find my style I'm pretty like new
to the game yeah classic kids try to hey
you know what do you want to do you know
passion stuff like that makes a lot of
sense but yeah so we were talking about
why you chose Stanford and you said it
was the easiest to get what I meant by
that is that like I don't have a good
chance to get into any of these schools
but like between like the 2% chance at
the other schools there was like a 5%
chance for Stanford mm-hmm which is why
I applied there all right that's a good
opportunity for me to get more
clarification question okay so don't say
anything to Elliott Elliott normally how
many practice tests do you take for like
these SATs wait was it SATs I took both
okay okay yeah so usually how many tests
would you take before taking the real
test
mm like this maybe like at least five up
to around 10 to 15 okay yeah because I
was just trying to get a feel if that
was a lot or not a lot so yeah you're
correct you do not study a lot yeah I
mean I I took a lot of like tests
growing out oh because like I got a
standardized test everywhere in the
other schooling system so good yeah not
in Canada we don't have that right
yeah that's why University of Waterloo
is a great school there's so many people
from Waterloo who really feel attacked
oh yeah because we're basically a
factory I'll just make like tech babies
and trim them off pretty much yeah
listen and I'm whatever but Stanford you
got to turn out like entrepreneurs you
know people care about you know like
snapchat you know it's gonna change the
world and stuff like that snakes I can
ask about you like how did you get into
like your school yeah like do you know
it's it's not that like well-known on
the east or like West Coast I'd say I
didn't even know about the school before
right where is it exactly
it's a Nashville Tennessee so it's like
down south yeah so what are your like
SAT scores and yeah I got a 35 on my
acct I never took that CT and I out of
36 oh okay yeah yeah and what else yeah
can you tell me about your was like the
common application or like essay stuff
honey what is it what did he ask you and
then like what Jews like why did you
think you got in what was your selling
point my cell was honestly my in Syria
my was doing a lot of photography oh and
I have talked about like I know I could
talk to about my violin but like every
agent of that or like my volunteering
when you play violin I play wow that's
pretty good
I'm saying their Sun fouled in know so I
talked about like my Instagram account
in high school I have like twenty four
five thousand and I was like growing it
and I thought I was like kind of unique
and I don't know I just thought it would
be pretty interesting to talk about
developed a story around it's a nice
that make sense
what was your selling point for Stanford
my selling point is that um I don't know
basically I'm the kid studying
communication mmm which nobody really
does mm-hmm so yeah yeah yeah well so
yeah so can you tell me a bit about like
what you guys are studying right now
right now I'm taking some film classes I
took some acting classes and I took once
the s class decided that it's not for me
so I have to cut that out for my Troma
Tech the channel and watch it all the
time
later on I'll tell you why you should
get to see us but okay okay okay so I
it's called human and organizational
development and I bought your business
minor it's too complicated to explain it
I see it's just business pretty much
like it's a liberal or at school so cool
just it's kind of wishy-washy
interesting in thatis thing so I mean
it's it's way too early for you guys but
I was still asking like what do you
envision yourself in like five years so
like what kind of job or how are you
guys gonna make money like you don't I
mean you don't have to but basically
what do you think you'll do in five
years after college I'm like really
interested in like marketing even maybe
pizza for tech and I like eventually
would love to be like entrepreneurship
and running my own thing I don't think
that's something where it's like super
force though then you have to be patient
with it and just get some experience and
learn about like the inner workings of
an industry before you can really be
like oh I'm gonna go create a amazing
solution for it if you don't know what
the problem is it's kind of difficult so
I just like want to try to work like a
traditional job for a little bit but
eventually they would love to do my own
thing
mmm I didn't thought that
okay yeah we all know who the better
student is okay question so once you
guys got you know pretty famous you know
Big Boi Chanel yeah what what kind of
questions do you guys get most often
asked on instagram or sorry my Instagram
just games I'm not curious that year a
lot of the earlier ones just people
telling me asking me to like read over
their applications so like for the first
couple months of my channel I was just
editing essays like 24/7 you actually
didn't afford him
yeah I did cuz like I started the
channel to try to help people because I
thought there was like an information
gap in the college application process
for kids who didn't get like counseling
and things like that yeah so I wanted to
help them but after a while I just I was
just drowning how are you hmm
I was it like I do get a lot of
questions from high schoolers as well
it's like oh what I do for like how do I
get into this college like I don't know
but I also get like some
entrepreneurship stuff like how do i you
know make some side money or videography
questions stuff like that then so are
you already making --side money right
now see how I transitioned so do you
make sign money right yes so you still
like flipping resale which was like my I
was making a lot in like high school
like thousands and I was like whatever
that's great and I invested all that
money into like an Amazon business doing
private label FBA what's private label
it's it's basically like you get a
product and you make your own branded
yourself and like like drop shipping a
little bit kind of but like drop
shipping is less company is like you use
all their people's products because in
private label you go through the
manufacturing process and the branding
and about it yeah so it's a lot on but
yeah I'm looking at all that money I
made through flipping and reselling I
lost through Amazon and really yeah
pretty much
and so yeah I am pretty much just
relying on YouTube in khoka YouTube
income yeah do you have any like side
businesses that are related to your
YouTube like do you do sponsor videos do
you sell something I am not selling
right now yeah pretty much just ad
revenue some small I've done like one
sponsorship in my total time on YouTube
I don't like doing them a lot and then
really really focus on monetization so I
just kind of like leave that alone I'm
trying to get back into it cuz it's like
it takes a lot of time you guys know
taking up a lot of time I was about to
say like yeah I hate it too but then
I'll probably have a sponsor
[Laughter]
okay all interesting okay um so how much
do you make for like YouTube and stuff
yeah Carolee so it really depends I'm
sure you guys know like from once a
month for me it's like all the check or
the the payment I get from YouTube is
around 1 to 2 K and it is could be a lot
higher if I actually I use a lot of
copyrighted music probably on 80% of my
videos so that's the reason why all my
biggest videos none of them are
monetized because I care a lot about
music and whatnot so like around how
many views per month do you get just so
that we can get a comparison on them
okay people want to be I would actually
put up I think probably at least a
million yeah mm-hmm I think maybe you
wanted to okay cool cool cool
so do you will get to use do you plan on
like expanding something new business
line or something you know like do you
do something for photography sure as of
right now really I'm just like exploring
I'm trying to tap into my creative side
a little bit more so not really focused
on you know I could roll out that course
or whatever like you know here's how you
get into college whatever I could do
that yeah I want to convey that and you
can make big bucks doing that and it's
pretty it's pretty easy so I would
arguably say like anyone who has a
sizable following and has some
informational you know power there can
like make a few hundred grand let's say
doing that and I know people who have
but really I'm not like trying to
monetize quick so that's it right now no
yeah what are they selling you've list
all ice courses the courses go for like
five hundred two thousand dollars I know
like people so like the Amazon thing I
know people who have like sold never
sold on Amazon sold a course they made
like around ten million off of that so
there's a lot especially in like
entrepreneurship there's a lot of
[ __ ] like what courses are good cuz
you don't there's no cost except your
time to make it once again you could
sell it I'll make sure that however
druggable product babies yeah nice maybe
I hear in my garage guy here micro what
does he have Taiwan plug tile oh oh yeah
yeah here's my garage he's a veteran
that's this whole dysfunction yeah just
like Dan lock I don't know if you've
ever so yeah they know there's people
it's all yeah yeah I mean if it works it
works I mean congrats on them yeah but
yeah anyways yeah back to you because
you said that people usually ask for
applications so you actually reviewed
their applications how long would it did
it take you to review them so like
they'd send me like their common app
essays like 650 words so it goes like 30
minutes 45 minutes just like reading
through it and leaving comments and
stuff like that that's a lie so what
we're like the general tips you would
say what makes an app good I guess for
me like the biggest problem I saw in
essays I read is that like you want to
make your essays enjoyable to read like
it doesn't have to be funny but like
it's like if someone picks it up they
want to finish it you know what I mean
mm-hmm
I don't know how to put that into words
it's basically just saying write better
it's like it'll retell yeah yeah yes so
we're talking a narrative up because
yeah there's a very good so what did you
write about in yours my comment up essay
I brought back some anecdote from
kindergarten when I did a show and tell
thing and I brought a dead bird mmm us
freaked out
I know sort of connected that to how I
just like like talking and like
presenting and performing things like
that and like all my ex other
extracurriculars
so I guess my narrative was literally my
life story and that's good I they seem
to like it that's cool yeah so are you
saying that like yeah you brought a bird
and then people freaked out or something
when I brought the bird and people
freaked out
I felt like empowered yeah I felt like
this is something I want to do which is
why I did speech in high school why I
made videos took you know film classes
things like that because I wanted to get
that same sort of feeling of Joe stell
interesting so what why do you think you
have this feel like why did it feel so
good when people freaked out over here I
don't know I guess since since I was a
kid I was always small and I was a
minority back then I lived in like Texas
so I was the only Asian kid so I always
felt like really invisible and once like
people started looking at me it just
felt good yeah you felt like a serial I
really like that yeah do you still feel
this like segregation a little bit maybe
not segregation but it like alienated
because you're asian-american in
Stanford or just in general here I'd say
in a Stanford in the Bay Area in general
I really don't feel that at home maybe
in like some like subsections of the
school like maybe if you go to like frat
houses you might feel a little off but
in general I never felt like any sort of
prejudice against me since I've been
here mm-hmm
what so when did you feel like prejudice
just like bouncing between like suburbs
like white suburbia like through most of
my childhood it's always like the only
Asian kid in the neighborhood yeah I
mean I had there they're all my friends
but looking back on it now there was
always some sort of divide okay can you
kind of elaborate on the Defiant yeah
like they like make jokes about like my
eyes and things like that and I just
sort of learned to just take it you know
they called me like [ __ ] or something
like that King kook et cetera and I just
sort of rolled with the punches I
thought gee I just took it because I
wanted to be friends with them but I
realize now that I couldn't be friends
with them because I'm never going to be
then man did you ever felt that like oh
I wish I wasn't Asian yeah definitely
for a lot a large part of my life but
yeah I mean I'm very comfortable with
being Korean Korean Korean oh you guys
are both Korean yeah actually makes
sense program extends oh I guess I just
spending a lot of time with my parents
learning about the Heritage and going to
Korea now and then I realize that it's a
good place to be cool cool what about
you how do you like did you ever felt
like you were alienated when you were
kids and stuff like that I feel like I
grew up in like New Jersey pretty
diverse area and
and when I went to high school I was
look I moved to Indiana for my high
school which is like it was pretty much
wipe suburbia too but I was lucky enough
to like have a pretty diverse community
there but I feel like the school I'm at
venerable it is that segregation there's
a lot of Greek life at Vanderbilt Greek
non-greeks most Greek is white and life
there is that segregation and literally
the other day I was just like looking at
Latin lunch and you can even like see
it's not on purpose or anything but
there's actually like segregation
implicitly and like I thought that was
pretty interesting I never really like
to notice that but you know I don't know
if that has to do with the fact that
like people you know are drawn to you
know there's similar communities I don't
know exactly but there is a divide and
like I thought I was like the knee
interesting cuz I never really recognize
it until like college to be honest yeah
yeah did you want to do see us like in
high school oh yeah that's a that's a
great question so I actually want to be
an investment banker yeah so I joined
math and business there was a program
that was called double degree and you do
math at Waterloo and then you do
business at another school and then I
want to be investment banker because I
didn't want to follow my brother's
footstep what he did was he dropped out
of the business he did the same program
but he dropped out of the business in
two semesters and he did math he was
like a big math nerd he did pure math
and he ended up being like a quantum
like a quantitative researcher I didn't
want to do that
I didn't even want to touch like stem
stuff I said you know I'm a sociable guy
I could be a businessman whatever that
means right so then I joined I joined
Waterloo and wilfrid laurier which is
the other course I started theater
College and after one semester I dropped
business because I just couldn't handle
it I was like oh my god it's so boring
and then it was after that I learned
about oh you know Facebook they pay a
lot for computer science I mean for
software engineers and Google and all
these cool jobs and then I just switched
from math to computer science I was
lucky because when I was taking math I
also was take
like cs4 fun because of that had a
credits to go into computer science but
uh but yeah and then even after I went
to do a few internships in software
engineering I still didn't really want
to do it because I thought I'm a
businessman I should do more like things
that is like a little bit more social so
that's why I changed the data science
and then I changed a product manager
because because back then I was very
ambitious I was I wanted to make a
startup or like I want to run a startup
or do my own thing right and then over
the years I you know I kind of
reevaluate and my values on what I care
about and in the end like there are some
other things I care about now and I feel
like right now software engineering is a
good fit for that yeah so yeah you guys
have any a study tips I'm not gonna lie
I'm a little lacking in this area but
like so are you getting bad grades right
now or no I'm not like getting bad
grades like the thing is like Stanford
grade inflation etc and as long as you
just start what's the great inflation
rate inflation basically means like if
there's a like a bell curve for like the
grade distribution and then it's like
skewed though so they arrange the median
is not like C no it's not it's like it's
probably round to be I think I read that
the average GPA Stanford is like a 3.7
or 3.8 oh interesting that's that's odd
but but then again are your grades
important nowadays because you're not
gonna go to correct I mean if I went to
grad school it's important but yeah the
only fields were great to really matter
I would say is probably like if you're
pre-med if you're going to like some
sort of stem graduate school like
physics or something or blah I'm not
really sure but other than that the
Stanford name on top of your degree will
probably matter more
the number beneath it mm-hmm a lot of
the types of schools like have Harvard
for example like people say it's hard to
get a four oh but it's like easy to get
like a three seven three eight okay
because they ever want to get well
because it was so hard to get in they
deserve that great info yeah I mean
right I know exactly how it works yeah
but like baby has like great deflation
yeah yeah a lot of school really so it's
like the average is addy it's all other
that's well weird yeah well that's
terrible
okay yeah I think MIT and Princeton also
a great deflation oh really
yeah so hard actually MIT I think has a
quota on a number of students I can get
A's in a class huh so they're literally
competing with each other yeah and I
don't know that seems toxic to me so
yeah yeah when I went to see Jeb which
is something in Quebec it's like pre
University we had something called a
Norse our score and it what it is is if
you're it it compares your your grades
with your classmates and so no one would
collaborate because if your classmates
do bad then you do well yeah alright is
is terrible so what about like um you
know now that you've started college do
you think you're very different from
when your high school like what are some
of the lessons that you've learned a lot
and you and you wish to pass it on to
kids our high school nurse right I think
it tastes a lot like in high school I
didn't really care about things I just
was always just doing enough to get by I
wasn't really ambitious or anything and
I did well enough I think just to know
do okay in school and when whatever and
even freshman year of college I'd say I
wasn't really like that driven or like
ambitious freshman year summer though I
spent as like three months alone in New
York and I really just got to do my own
thing and explore and I think I really
thought about like where I wanted to be
in the future and that really helped me
be grounded and in my goals and my
ambitions so I think I've changed a lot
since then
yeah I mean like a lot of people change
in college just because you're exposed
to new perspectives it's a different
world and like it's not the real world
yet but it's one step closer so like
your eyes are open
- opened up to a lot more information
and perspectives well the first two
years of high school I was slacking off
like I said I had this weird concept
that being cool and not studying like
the cool kids so I just didn't study but
junior senior year I was so like
romantically attached to the idea of
getting into a good school that I worked
my ass off like really hard but now that
I'm here at Stanford it's like if since
I don't have an end goal in mind I guess
have like a bit of perspective I don't I
don't like work as hard mostly because I
don't have anything to work towards at
the moment I mean it it's a hard thing
to do right like I'll give you a
comparison in a company we have
something called like a goal metric or
an okay are it's something that the
company worked towards - right but it's
not always correct it doesn't always
lead to the right path and the most
dangerous thing you can do is following
it blindly and then realizing that
that's not what you want right so I mean
I think it's totally okay that you don't
have a goal anymore but it's nice to try
to think about it and know at least what
kind of direction you want to go to I
mean I feel like you kind of know what
you want especially for now it's like
you want to own your own thing you want
I'm guessing you want to do your own
thing run your own business kind of a
thing right
yeah it changes everybody we exactly
chain activities every two weeks I can
think about it and literally within a
month it could be complete opposites
it's just like thinking long-term like
what I really want out of life in order
so do you not even have like a slightest
of an idea of a goal or something I want
to work towards too late it can be
anything like oh I want to be more
honest person I want to write funnier
person right like yeah I think what I've
concluded is that if I am if we're gonna
work on anything it has to be sort of
creative mmm I need to have my own input
on it because I've tried like sort of
busy work like desk jobs and I just I
don't know I don't think I can do that
so whatever I'm doing it's probably
going to involve sort of what I'm doing
already maybe like YouTube or just
maybe writing just anything in that sort
of industry area who Nydia entertainment
etc yeah imagine if you guys can do
YouTube like full-time imagine if every
job paid the same what would you do
would it be YouTube or something else I
mean all things considered if you could
do YouTube as a career it's an amazing
thing you can work at your own pace you
can just do whatever you want
so I mean yeah it wouldn't be bad my
only problem with it is that your budget
is not as high as like if you worked and
like the film industry or something like
if I if I wanted to make a feature film
in the future you can't do that on
YouTube mm-hmm I mean you could be a
creative director or like a direct a
movie director that that's also
possibility right right you know yeah I
don't yeah I guess like imagine if you
could do anything anything not
constraint to you to or something else
you could do anything anything what
would you do I don't know think of it I
would probably say like movie directing
would be if I was good enough would be a
dream I personally think like YouTube
allows me to fulfill a lot of what I
want out of life and that's not just
like super career driven goals it's like
I want to meet people who are doing cool
things and surround myself with those
types of people and YouTube has allowed
me to do that which is great that it
aligns with that goal it also allows me
to like travel and explore and that has
also been like one of my long-term goals
kind of like Barbie was saying about
like having something where he can
really express his creativity I think
like YouTube really does kind of allow
me to do that and I've realized like
recently that's like super important to
me so yeah I think like time so yeah
considering if it was like more
sustainable in the long term like it
could definitely be viable or reasonable
for me to pursue but you know in the
real world I don't think I would ever do
it like full-time mmm so what's like the
future of your channels but actually
before talking about the future what was
the origin of your channel like why did
you start it because sometimes it might
not be like what it is now like you
might have started for another reason
like my channel and a scary huh right I
guess I'd really plan to start a channel
just at
summer break last year when I was when I
just graduated high school I knew I
wanted to make a video on college essays
like I said to help like the information
gap and then um winter break of this
year of my first year at Stanford I was
just bored and I decided to make some
videos and it's just been sort of going
like that ever since yeah so for me I
was in high school I got into Vanderbilt
I searched a veiner book on YouTube and
I could not find any other videos other
than this five year old video of this
guy interviewing drunk people and I knew
like daily life videos we're doing well
and I saw that same in tech right so
it's like okay should I like create a
dating life Peter for Vanderbilt so in
my mind it made a lot of sense because I
wanted that when I was in high school
there was nothing to watch on and so I
decided to make one and I was like all
these videos are getting millions of
views
I can make one that's like okay you know
or even half that would be amazing so I
just went off and made it and yeah I
mean I made I started my channel just
like make that video and then it after
like three weeks it's sort of doing well
and I was like yeah I was like oh what
was the heck's going on but like I
realized at that moment like that was an
opportunity to ride that momentum and
you know this like once you get on the
YouTube train it's really hard to get
off but I read the momentum and I just
said like okay well now I'm just ready
to momentum like that I can't really
like a foot I love what I do so it's
like it's great for mmm Stephanie good
to write a momentum I did the same thing
right I did like a daily life of a
Facebook engineer and just blew all like
it blew up and that's what started my
channel
pretty much but yeah so if ever anyone
wants to make a youtube channel you
should start that and there's a lot of
people in are like the college news
mm-hmm there's a lot of people popping
yeah you guys are the future generation
of youtubers like soon I'll become
irrelevant like in a few years like my
channel be irrelevant will be filled a
few guys you guys would be like the next
generation so yeah and it's funny cuz um
I actually watch a lot of these videos
and I always keep tabs on them and it's
fun to see cuz some of them like yes you
can get millions of you for your day in
the life video but if you don't sustain
that
or if you have nothing to say like it
doesn't last for long there's a lot of
people that get like 2 million views
there are 3 million views but then their
future videos nobody care anymore but
yeah so um yeah make sure you engage
your audience yeah I agree with that
that's why I'm I guess my approach is
quite different where like I saw the
potential and like making a bunch of
Stanford videos like I do and I still
sort of have a quota like I shouldn't
make one every so often to make sure I'm
still on the radar but what I noticed
about like you know like channels you
sent to make one like video that pop off
like people subscribe or people view
feed about one type of content and if
they can't sustain that then nobody like
wants to watch them so I guess what I'm
trying to build is like people want to
watch a meal and not like the type of
video I'm making or like maybe they
here's interested in my life and I even
if it's a bit slower I think I
definitely appreciate that more it's
very true cuz like um the way how I
thought about it when I start making my
made my channel was that I made the
startup series
to sustain people by made all like the
[ __ ] like how to get into tech that
was to drive real audience right and and
you can also think about it in a way
where you just title it in a way that is
very you know external to external via
but then once they wash your video
they're like oh my god this guy is funny
oh my god this guy's you know so that
they can relate to you and stuff like
that but yeah have you guys did people
recognize you at school or like you know
on the streets and stuff you know how
did it feel the first time I guess for
me I've always like when I first got
here I I sort of enjoy feeling invisible
because I like to just observe and like
I do like bringing the dead bird
yeah same right right but like that's in
like a specific setting or more like
people are there to look at me like
otherwise like I'm not very social
because I don't know I like to think to
myself so when people started
approaching me in recognizing me it was
sort of weird because I felt like just
this little freshman at the school just
trying to learn things and people are
like approaching me I also choked really
hard when people approach me or really
bunch of like kids who like show up to
me and it's like oh I watch your videos
and I'm like me too
and yeah I don't know it so it's a lot
to take in definitely good cool cool
nice nice
alright would you guys like the second
part of the video where you just I just
tour around my apartment sure thing
alright let me